a lot of people have uh questions
regarding knowledge okay so let's go on
with that and uh where do we start here
when we start with a person who uh
essentially
criticized the notion that knowledge is
something that you have to prove to
someone else
okay because that uh you know knowledge
essentially by the greece was defined as
belief no difference between knowledge
and belief if anything knowledge is
deeper belief you believe more strongly
when you have knowledge that when you
just believe that's more or less it but
it all goes down to you
uh knowledge is something you have
yourself because belief is what you have
yourself and there are different degrees
and we say that 100 belief is knowledge
more or less that's that's the notion
and but i'm saying that uh now there's
something that you must prove to someone
else um that's the only way that uh we
can really use that in a way that we've
been using at all these years you know
how do you prove knowledge in college
well you go up there and you try to
pursue the teachers that you know that
means you're going to try to convince
them that you know of your beliefs
okay that you know what you studied
or you think you know at least okay so
this file says no you don't prove
knowledge to someone else
so he says the following says knowledge
need include proving something to others
knowledge exists as soon as it is
discovered
not as soon as is proven to enough
people
i see
well um
let's first put my definition so that
you can see
why he uh where he comes with all this
with his version his rejoinder
essentially okay and this is it despite
deriving from the word knowledge
uh science has nothing to do with
knowledge okay so the word seeded that's
where science comes from has to do with
the word no or knowledge and uh that's
where the word science comes from that's
the etymology but we don't care our
forefathers screwed it up from the start
when they
identified science with knowledge okay
so we're criticizing that we're
negating that and we're saying that no
the science has nothing to do with
knowledge science has to do with
explanations okay
and
now this this is our definition now is
predicting to others right the result of
an experiment without error
that's what all these people have been
saying all these years that's what we're
arguing here we're saying that knowledge
is what you prove to others okay
and
not even god omniscient god can predict
the uh result of an experiment without
error
if if he can without air that means the
future already exists uh the block
universe you know general relativities
block the universe
and you can take it all the way to the
days of augustine saint augustine and
you'll find that you know they've always
had this notion of the black universe
that god sees the future the past the
present everything at the same time so
that's the blocked universe but if
that's the case then you if you believe
in that you accept that you accept that
um assumption
um well that reduces you to a cartoon
character that means that you're you're
just
following footsteps that you cannot
avoid because everything the future has
already been determined
okay so if the future is already there
and you're then all you're doing is
walking in footsteps and you're no
different than bugs bunny and a cartoon
character
so hopefully you don't accept that as an
assumption or as a belief that uh the
future already exists
is there it's already made up because if
you do you
have no um free will meaning that you
know whatever crime you command you're
off the hook because you know you had no
choice you were forced to do it because
that was the script you you just
followed script whether you knew it or
not you know had the file script it was
already the cards were already thrown so
that's the problem with accepting
uh
[Music]
that we know
okay and no again means uh like it says
they're predicting to others the result
of an experiment without error and you
cannot predict uh and some people say
well yeah i can predict that yeah let me
get this out of here
i can predict that um this pencil is
going to fall to the floor
downwards
uh 100 of the time
and you know i can play a joke on you
and put a couple magnets and have it
stand in the air
or maybe i don't even need that maybe an
asteroid comes and destroys the earth
and your prediction didn't come true of
course i can't collect my bet
or maybe it kills you alone and you
didn't get to you know prove your
experiment so we cannot be uh we cannot
prove
without air anything in the future
that's the issue okay anything go wrong
usually it doesn't or sometimes it does
murphy's law right but
you cannot predict everything in the
future 100 that's the point so there is
no such thing as knowledge but that is
the definition of the word knowledge
that we can use consistently
and you say well is that true
okay so let's go through it let's uh
first look what the greeks said about
knowledge and i covered that uh the
other day knowledge a true judgment with
an account in other words justify true
belief that came from the mouth i guess
of socrates and uh plato uh wrote it in
his book the aethedis um but he put the
words he gave credit to socrates okay so
uh yeah knowledge is just justified true
belief that means you you're justified
yourself right in believing it that's
all that knowledge is and again i call
it deep
belief it's a
knowledge it's just a deeper belief than
regular belief you could say that's all
it is but it all dies with you okay
according to the greeks and according to
the notions that we have today and i'm
trying to change that i'm saying look we
don't have the any use for the word
knowledge and science but if you're
going to use it this is what you always
have meant by it the only way you can
use it consistently and that is
predicting without air the results of an
experiment
i mean if you go to college and uh
you're in front of the
uh board they're trying to get your
degree you you are going to try to prove
your knowledge to them how do you prove
it
you know uh well you're running an
experiment and you say this what's going
to happen you know i put the
uh
red liquid with a green liquid and it
turns uh blue
you can say something and then you
explain why maybe and then uh so now you
have an explanation you have you you
predicted the results of the experiment
that you were about to run
that's how you prove it can you prove
the past
well let's find out let's look at some
of the uh uses that we have with the
word no or the word knowledge and we're
going to see
why it's become so complex to understand
the word knowledge and why people have
uh irrational notions of what knowledge
is let's go with the first one okay here
do you know that uh for example the
pythagorean
theorem
that's c squared equals a squared plus b
squared do you know that the number pi
for sure that circumference divided by
diameter is equal to 314 et cetera et
cetera et cetera
force equals mass times acceleration
equals mc squared
you say well i know this
you do do you
so what did you just say what do you
mean you know it what is the definition
of knowledge if you're going to say that
you know that this that you know this
so i need a definition of the word
knowledge before you can say i know that
this is true or whatever that i know
this
okay maybe you memorized it
did you run an experiment how do you
know this okay so that's the first one
did you just memorize it in high school
and you say i know it meaning you can
recite it
so i need a definition of the word no if
you're gonna use it to say that you know
any of these things or any other
equation or whatever you find out there
okay that's the first one
let's go with the second one here um
do you know history
do you know that alex the great slept
with epheston do you know that uh caesar
across the rubicon in
49 bc do you know that hitler attacked
france in 1940 were you there i mean and
even if you were there this doesn't it's
worthless because
are you going to prove it to me how are
you going to prove for example that neil
armstrong
right stepped on the moon in 1969 today
how are you going to prove that you're
going to run an experiment and say look
this is the foot of neil armstrong and
this is how he stepped on the moon in
1969
is that how it's done is that how you
prove
that man stopped down the moon for the
first time
so you can see we're going to use the
word no in different contexts here and
what i need is a definition of the word
no that includes all of them
if you cannot define it with all of them
then we got a problem because you you
cannot say that you know that neil
armstrong stepped on the moon in 1969
that you know that uh circumference
divided by diameters pi you can't say
you know
because you haven't defined the word no
i don't know what you mean when you say
no
okay so that's going to be the issue
here
okay here's another context okay do you
know that you have a head
do you
know that you cut your hand you're
bleeding you that you have two legs and
that there's a wall
to your right do you know this say yeah
i know
well what does it mean
how are you going to define the word no
in such a way to encompass all of these
different situations that's the question
before you
okay let's see if we get it right
here's another one another context okay
do you know that god exists
how about time has warped you know uh
space time
time has worked
do you know that time has worked
or do you believe it
uh do you know that a particle can be at
two places at once do you know that
black holes
suck
and do you know
do you know
[Music]
yeah you gotta define the word no if
you're gonna be using it in a scientific
context because people want to include
the word knowledge no into science okay
fine define it in such a way that we can
use it consistently in all of these
contexts okay
if you're going to eliminate one of the
context you got to justify why because
you know i know history i know that
napoleon went to waterloo in 1815 and he
said well that's not knowledge okay then
why isn't it knowledge do we believe
that we belie but we don't believe um
uh we we don't believe that um
uh circumference divided by diameter
is pi
314
that's not a belief that's that's a
knowledge
and you say well i can apply it in
technology i can do stuff with circles
and diameters and so on well socrates
already
killed that one uh 3 000 years ago okay
so just check uh the theaters and you'll
find that he already tore that notion
down okay so you got to read it okay
okay how about this one uh do you know
that uh spoon will fall when i get let
go of it
do you know this
and you say well i do know uh you know
here's a uh
here spoon okay little spoon we let go
of it it falls down
and it turns out that you know uh
i had air pushing from below just when
you threw it
and so you did not know that it was
going to fall because standing in the
air
oh you tricked me irrelevant
irrelevant because the issue was whether
you knew whether you could predict the
result of that experiment without air
okay do you know that the sun will rise
tomorrow do you know that there will be
an eclipse in a minute there in that
situation where the
moon is covering the sun
do you know
what do you mean you know
what's the definition of knowledge
that's the question do you know that the
plane will crash you know some things we
say well that's going to happen
and maybe something else happens and it
doesn't happen with the way you thought
it was gonna your knowledge was not
complete for some reason
okay how about this one
do you know johnny
uh do you know where he lives
do you know who your boss is do you know
you're left from your right hand right
um
like i said in other languages
like spanish and german they have
different words for for these types of
knowledge when you know johnny uh they
don't use the word no they have a
different word for those almost in every
language the only one that i know is
english that doesn't uh have a word for
those which is kind of it's it's like
acquaintance more than knowledge okay
but anyways uh again you got to define
the word knowledge in order for us to
use it all these different contexts okay
here's another
uh knowledge
and here we're gonna be talking about
theories okay here it is do you know
what causes gravity
is that the same thing as knowing that
napoleon went to waterloo
i mean are we talking about the same
type of knowledge here
uh
do you know that a magnet attracts
another is this knowledge or
or
are you supposed to provide a mechanism
an explanation a physical interpretation
do you know what electricity is do you
know what prevents the earth from flying
out of the solar system these are the
questions that you've got to answer uh
if you're going to define the word
knowledge and include within science and
i'm saying the only one that is
applicable and again there's no
knowledge but the only one that would be
applicable is
the notion that we have where you prove
to someone else your knowledge if you're
on an island all by yourself and you cut
your arm you say well i know i cut my
arm i see it i feel it i know i cut my
heart i know i have a head i know i have
two arms i know i have two legs you know
you you know this
but see what whatever knowledge you have
yourself it's just a belief what's the
difference between belief and knowledge
if you're the only person on in the
universe
now there's just something you're gonna
show someone else you're gonna say let
me show you that i know
because otherwise you just have a belief
and if you're going to say look i cut
myself i know i cut myself but i'm on
the other side of the world i can't see
you or whatever
you know what am i supposed to say that
you believe until you prove it to me
so again the issue is defining the word
knowledge in such a way that you can use
it consistently in science if you're
going to bring that word into science
such that you can use it in all these
contexts if you reject any of the
context you have to also justify why
because that's how it's used in ordinary
speech in all these contexts